faire de la peinture nianga c'est
d'abord un cérémonial celui de fabriquer
ses propres couleurs pour le goff ou la
peinture blanche il faut jeter 100 fois
son mélange dans un bol pour l'affiner
pour les autres couleurs c'est plus
simple
vous prépare sa peinture avec de la
colle à dubaï et des pigments avec les
doigts parce que c'est le meilleur moyen
de sortir que le le pigment est bien 10
ou au pinceau on veut pas sentir ça
ça devient ça devient quelque chose qui
fait partie intégrante de cet art de
prendre le temps au fait de préparer
chaque pigments
le motif est destiné à l'anc puis on
ajoute des couches successives sur le
washi le papier qui remplace la toile
éloge de la patience
si je n'ai qu'une seule couche par
exemple n'avoir qu'une seule couleur
alors que si je superpose des couches
qui vont être plus ou moins mouillé je
pourrais obtenir des transparences et
des vibrations
d'abord peintre de décor valérie et
douchy s'est tourné vers le nylon gars
depuis 2007 elle expose régulièrement
dans des galeries
il ya une sensualité des pigments le
côté
velouté visuellement et aussi le travail
de yoga et procure devra les tentes par
exemple je prendrai des laits végétaux
j'essaie de traduire
comment dire une émotion j'ai ressenti
au moment où j'étais saoul hasard votre
regard des ailes et bien à travers les
feuillages jeu j'essaie de retrouver cet
état qui est un état
particulièrement agréable et de
l'inscrire avec des pigments
[Musique]